I told you last week that within minutes
of finishing my livestream of the first
day of Trump impeachment hearings CNN
filed a copyright claim on my six hour
livestream which I spent all day
producing instantly taking the video
offline instantly cutting off views
instantly cutting off revenue to that
video now I reached out to CNN and I
appealed the claim and I said hey we
didn't use one damn second of CNN video
please release the claim and by the
following morning the claim had been
released
despite being completely bogus we did
lose views and monetization for many
many hours during a key time that people
were interested in that video sad but we
moved on Friday I did another six hour
livestream and in addition to that day's
broadcast we did audience questions on
the stream the full hearing so on and so
forth and it happened again but this
time it's even worse this time it wasn't
just CNN that claimed revenue and
blocked the video so did NBC News now as
a reminder we did commentary on the
hearings using a c-span feed of the
impeachment hearings House of
Representatives proceedings are funded
by my tax dollars and your tax dollars
and c-span's broadcasts of House
proceedings are in the public domain we
did not use a single second of NBC
coverage nor CNN coverage and yet I get
an email from YouTube saying the david
pakman show impeachment hearing day two
has received acclaim from NBC News this
instantly became indistinguishable from
parody and we instantly lose the revenue
from the video we spent all day
producing now of course I immediately
appeal I email my YouTube rep I mean
email anyone I know and within a few
hours
NBC releases the claim thank you so much
we can now monetize the video again and
within it must have been no more than
five minutes of NBC releasing the claim
I start getting emails from viewers
saying David your entire video of that
stream
and your commentary has been blocked by
CNN on copyright grounds this now has to
be a parody right this can't be real I'm
sure someone just made a Photoshop that
makes it look like the video was taken
down but oh I check my email and yes the
david pakman show impeachment day too
has now received a claim from CNN what
and I check and this time unlike with
NBC where we merely lost monetization
CNN has blocked the entire video so once
again I appeal I start emailing everyone
I know and eventually it was unblocked
this is not how this is supposed to work
now this time fortunately this is
actually getting attention reclaim the
net published an article called David
Pakman hit with NBC News Content ID
claim on YouTube video containing none
of their footage we're good for them
reclaim the net actually wrote about
what's going on where they say quote
YouTube's broken copyright system is at
it again
political commentator David Pakman
coverage of today's impeachment hearing
against President Trump was hit with a
Content ID claim from NBC News despite
the video containing none of their
footage now this is where it starts to
get interesting this article in reclaim
the net led to some lawyers reaching out
to me and of course as much as they want
to help this is not easy to fight
because this is how the system is
supposed to work this is an automatic
Content ID system that works for big
media against shows like mine and so
many others that you probably watch it
gives the benefit of the doubt to the
computerized algorithm that supports CNN
and NBC and others and it makes me the
little guy have to prove that I didn't
break the rules so again we're talking
to lawyers I'm seeing if we can fight
this in any more systematic way but in
the meantime we're just gonna keep doing
what we're doing keep signing up on our
website for memberships to make that
YouTube revenue as irrelevant as we can
a hundred and seventy-five people thank
you signed up for memberships since we
got hit last week and I so appreciate
you doing that let's keep it going david
pakman.com
slash membership memberships are really
cheap I won't spend a lot of time on
this they really help us even if you
contribute three bucks a month by using
the coupon code half 19 which saves you
50% that 3 dollars a month is way way
way more than we make from any one
viewer on YouTube that I can assure you
any one viewer you know we make
fractions of a cent from on YouTube so
you were doing so much good please keep
doing it I'll keep you posted about
anything legal that we can do or that we
choose to do but it is very very ugly
and it is unfortunately I mean listen
all I can do is we've got to do the
streams that our audience wants us to do
these impeachment hearing streams have
gotten six to seven thousand live
concurrent viewers for a six hour period
that is a really successful stream for
us it is highly engaging we get
subscribers we get members and super
chat questions we're gonna keep doing it
and then if we have to fight for the
revenue once those videos are archived
I'm ready to do it it sounds like we
have people who are willing to help us
do it and we're gonna try to fix the
system if we can but if we can't we will
work within it and do everything that we
can to keep doing this content and to
keep providing the commentary so that's
where we are today sadly it I know it
seems satirical we had this happen on
Wednesday and then it happens EE on
Friday but it is what it is I'll keep
you informed about how it continues